[Music]
you
um
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hi welcome to the table uh
my name is don jacobs and i'm actually
one
part of the eldership team that is here
at the table and
that is probably the very first time
i've actually said that out loud
um so um that's kind of
kind of different for me uh so i but i
just want to say thank you for
um coming and participating and um
being a part of this and we are actually
kind of on a countdown
i'm looking forward to this very soon we
are about to
uh resume in-person uh services
uh so i'm looking forward to that
because i can see
faces um you know they might be masked
faces but they're going to be faces
i don't worry about trying to do some of
this stuff looking at a camera
i'm trying to make sure my lighting's
right am i in the frame just so
uh already that kind of stuff from that
kind of goes into the
uh some of this park the social
distancing parts i'm
i'm looking forward to seeing people um
having those
you know conversations that sometimes
that we have sometimes missed
um being able just to talk in between
you know before service or after service
and things like that so i'm looking
forward to that
that's coming up april the 11th we still
have
many other things are going to be
happening but do pay attention to april
11th that is going to be
our uh resume in person service um at
pleasant valley
um we will still be doing some online
things so those of you who are
are still wanting to participate online
absolutely we want you to
not only feel like that you're safe but
being able to just have that ability to
do so
but we will also will be doing both
uh in-person and online service um at
that time
but we do have several other dates that
uh you need to make sure you keep
in mind and in your calendar um
that right now march the 26th uh
is a volunteer opportunity for the five
loaves food pantry um so if you
we've been talking about five lowe's
food pantry for quite some time uh
if you give to the table um part of that
contribution actually goes to help
support
um that local food transfer that's in
the taxi area and so this is an
opportunity for us to kind of see the
behind the scenes help volunteer out
just a little bit
um and just kind of see how the whole
entire process works
um so i know i'm planning on on being
there i'm looking forward to it
um it's going to be the the time for
that's going to be like from five to
seven
and there's gonna be a link where you
can sign up
um if you're planning on participating
as well um so that's going to be also
in the notes below so kind of check that
out
um if you can't arrive right at five
o'clock it's okay if you're
come you know a little bit late uh
that's not not a problem but
uh if you have questions um email
miranda phillips
i also think her email's gonna be below
in the notes as well
uh another date to keep in mind is april
2nd uh that is good friday and our
service will be online
uh so just kind of save the date for
that and then
one other date to kind of keep in mind
is april the 4th
uh this is going to be our easter
service now our location is going to be
still be
two to be determined but it is going to
be in the morning
so it's a little bit different than what
we've been doing but it is
it's about 10 30. um our location we're
still trying to
figure that out but we're thinking it's
going to be somewhere in the garland
area
so it's still going to be somewhat local
for most of us
so just kind of keep that in mind but
yeah those are that's a lot of that's a
lot of information
uh to kind of keep track of but yeah
we've got a lot of amazing things
happening
um again i'm looking forward to our
in-person uh services that we're gonna
be resuming here pretty soon
so with that being said um let's i want
to transition us with a prayer
into our worship time lord
thank you so much thank you for
just again this ability to get together
to be able to
still be able to have our community as
the table
and to be able to meet online to be able
to
support each other to care for one
another to
um be able to be so we can begin to see
a light at the end of the tunnel too
and um some of these um
the social distancing practices that
we've been doing for so so long
um i pray that you open up our hearts
open our minds for what's been prepared
for us today
with worship with a word from rhett
i pray that um you just uh have
us walk away with the things that you
need us
to be prepared for this next week in
christ i pray
amen
hey table family hi
we um are gonna spend some time this
week talking about
the pain um that produces
change and transformation in our lives
and um
it reminded me so much i don't know if
you guys have been on spring break we've
been on spring break this week
we've been spending a lot of days
outside
gardening and it has not been the kind
of gardening where you just
it's not picture perfect garden not like
the ones where it's like
you know you have on the cute gloves and
you put the new plant in the ground and
it looks so pretty
this has been what kind of gardening
deconstruction
deconstruction gardening like ripping
things out by their roots and i'm not
talking about like little things i'm
talking about like
a forest we have just
been tearing things apart here
and without any vision of the future
it honestly just feels very bleak when
you look in our backyard right now
um there were a lot of dying plants that
needed to come out that hadn't been
tended to for years and years and
um and sometimes like the only way
forward
is through kind of this
journey of um pain honestly
through through the uprooting through
the
detangling of you know dead roots and
um soil that hasn't been stirred up in a
long time and
anyways it was just a great picture for
me going into this week as we prepared
for worship and thinking through the way
that god works in our lives sometimes
and how he's able to use our pain
to produce beauty not because he's
coming and inflicting pain on
us um i don't want to get into that kind
of gospel that's not the god i believe
in
um but i have seen him use
some of my most painful moments
to um weave together this story of
redemption
and the story of deeper faith and um
yeah really producing in me in those
moments
humility and uh compassion
and um a larger capacity to love
do you remember in our bedroom growing
up
we always share the bedroom but that
frenzies the quote that i
had written on our bulletin board in our
room that said pain is the breaking of
the shell that encloses
my understanding okay do you remember
that again
pain is the breaking of the shell that
encloses our understanding um
just let that sink in but i did that
just
came to mind as you were speaking no
that's so good
yeah it's kind of what you're saying
that is that is that's a
so that's all i have to say that sums it
up
honestly though that's really the spirit
behind this set is um
us allowing god to use even
our moments of pain and discomfort that
can be so
disorienting um
not to negate that or belittle that you
know
the disorientation that comes sometimes
from our deconstruction from our pain
our questions
our doubts our disbelief um even the
things that have been done to us by
others that were intended for harm
because those happen but i have been
so blown away um
by these moments where i watch god
transform those kinds of moments into
glory
into um deeper relationships into
faith and trust and um yeah just a lot
of beauty
so anyways um let's set our eyes
fix our eyes on the author and perfecter
of our faith
who is able to do so much more than we
realize in the moment
so you guys join with us as we kind of
venture into that territory
[Music]
sometimes vulnerability we guard
ourselves
for good reason sometimes um
but right now i just ask that you would
help us to open up
and allow you to do your work
transformation your work
of kindness and redemption in our lives
[Music]
you are my face
i
[Music]
i believe
friends
[Music]
i believe you are
i believe
and it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
[Music]
[Applause]
because they can't stay long
when i'm here with you
it's a new horizon and i'm set on you
and you leave me here today
all my fears
[Music]
me
the life i believe
[Music]
[Applause]
now
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you lead me here
mercies today are new
all my fears
in second corinthians 4 it says
but we have this treasure in jars of
clay
to show that this almost surprising
power
is from god not from us
[Music]
we always carry around in our bodies the
death of jesus
so that the life of jesus
may also be revealed
[Music]
you've brought me to the end of myself
you gave
[Music]
falling into
i confess i still get scared
sometimes the perfect love comes
[Music]
my
[Laughter]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
now
oh
[Music]
please
fish
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
my wisdom
son
[Music]
is
brightness
[Music]
still be my vision
oh
[Music]
in our lives
we would allow you to come be the vision
that gets us through the pain
the pressure and when the water is
rising and the heat turns up
god that we would look to you that we
would fix our eyes on you
and trust the goodness
of your grace in our lives to carry us
through to transform us god
that your refining fire would do its
work in our hearts
we trust you and love you
and want more of you in our lives
in jesus name amen amen
thanks guys
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
and welcome to the table i am
uh very very excited to be with you not
only tonight of course but
as don mentioned earlier uh we'll be
back in april
and uh it's been a long road so i'm i'm
really excited
uh and just to kind of reiterate so we
will be online
for our good friday service so that's
april 2nd um but then we'll meet
outdoors
at a venue um in the kind of garland
sexy area that'll be for easter morning
april 4th we'll meet outside somewhere
and then our first sunday back
at the the church that we um rented a
year ago pleasant valley united
methodist church in saxi
uh we'll be back there the 11th so um
yeah it should be a really great kind of
holy week leading up to easter
and uh and then after that wonderful to
to be with you all
in person so uh this is
part um four in our series titled
uh lent from repentance to renewal
and um you know when we talk about lint
in the christian context
we are not of course referring to the
stuff very deep in your pockets
but rather uh l-e-n-t
not i e-n-t which comes from the latin
word
uh linkedin which stood for the spring
season and so
in a christian context it refers to that
that spring season of fasting
in spiritual preparation uh leading up
to good friday and then easter so
if you haven't already i encourage you
to uh join us by
either giving something up that your ego
just like craves uh or by taking up a
new spiritual practice maybe prayer
scripture reading
turning off your phone at 6 pm you know
i don't know
whatever uh kind of whatever god leads
you
to do so all right with that in mind the
title of my message tonight is
be the fire be the fire
and um i want to name up front that
uh i as i was doing my research i i came
across
um kind of an analysis of this passage
um and a take on it from bishop t.d
jakes who of course um is a pastor at
the potter's house in dallas
um and he's a wonderful preacher and uh
so he helped me see
the snakes in a new way uh
so i want to give him credit for this um
now you say the snakes
what is going on what an exciting night
so that brings us to our scriptures
um for today so the first is from the
old testament book of numbers
uh chapter 21 verses four through nine
and then we have a text from the gospel
of
john chapter 3 verses 14 and 15 and our
very own graham branson
will be doing those readings tonight
so take it away
hi i'm graham branson i'm going to be
reading a couple passages today
the first ones numbers 21 verses 4
through 9
the bronze snake they traveled from
mount hore
along the route to the red sea to go
around edom
but the people grew impatient on the way
they spoke against god and against moses
and said why have you brought us up out
of egypt to die
in the wilderness there's no bread
there's no water
and we detest this miserable food then
the lord sent
venomous snakes among them they bit the
people
and many israelites died the people came
to moses and said
we sin when we spoke against the lord
and against you
pray that the lord will take the snakes
away from us
so moses prayed for the people the lord
said to moses
make a snake and put it up on a pole
anyone who is bitten can look at it and
live
so moses made a bronze snake and put it
up on a pole
and then when anyone was bitten by a
snake and looked at the bronze snake
they lived now i'll read john
3 verses 14 and 15. just
as moses lifted up the snake in the
wilderness
so the son of man must be lifted up that
everyone who believes may have eternal
life in him
thank you take it away brett
take it away graham i like you you can
tell he's a school teacher because he's
like
you know he's a good reader he's got
that that vibe so
um all right so all right while
um numbers 21 i want to kind of start
there i
i get that may strike you as a
uh i don't know how does it hit you as
somewhat strange
maybe even a bit problematic i mean god
is like killing people with snakes as
punishment
um but this is one of those moments
where
i think we need to to not get overly
lost and somewhat intellectually and
even kind of morally like hung
up at the literal level of the story
um this is something i've talked about
before if you want resources i can point
you in the right direction of past
sermons um so instead i think
like the church fathers and mothers um
we need to hear the story figuratively
that is kind of metaphorically we need
to be
open um to what god might be saying
to us we need to hear the story with
spiritual ears so to speak we need to
read it with
spiritual eyes um because in reading it
that way
um i mean as second timothy 3 16 17
names like all scripture is god-breathed
and useful
it's useful for teaching for rebuking
for correction for
training and righteousness and uh and
and when we can kind of see the story
through that lens um i think it really
is
quite a a rich um narrative
so let me kind of go back a bit and kind
of recap this
so the lord had um brought the children
of israel
later they'd be known as the jewish
people but that term wasn't really in
use yet so they're the israelites
and so he brings them out of egypt
with as the bible says a mighty hand
and an outstretched arm he had you know
brought them
through the waters of the red sea he had
done miracle after miracle
uh but they are um like us you know
uh human all too human and so at this
point in the journey
um they are tired and they are hungry
and they are stressed
and so they begin to grow impatient
that's the word that's used in verse
four impatient
you ever grow impatient uh sometimes
you know i get the idea i kind of get
the sense like hey i'm really starting
to
kind of getting somewhere on the
spiritual
journey towards christ's likeness so to
speak
i you know i kind of start thinking like
i can tell it's working
it's working and um and then
god makes me wait and
this i cannot stand like i mean i can
suffer a thousand sufferings
just don't make me go slow
slower than i want i my
um my kryptonite is a long line
and and and i mean that kind of
metaphorically too right like just in
life
that's like i just i don't like the
patience
lesson so to speak so this is where the
people are
right they're just like me they're just
like you the people they're growing
impatient
and this impatience leads to words uh
stupid words
why have you brought us out of egypt
into the wilderness to die
uh as graham read so eloquently there's
no bread
there's no water and we detest this
miserable food that's a great quote
so i mean but notice that you know the
previously
oppressed people um they're now
you know complaining that their food
isn't good enough right like all you've
done god is provide this miraculous
substance called mana
to sustain us through the years of our
journey but you didn't even make it
taste
awesome and again i mean this is what i
would have done
like just you know human all too human
and how quickly
how quickly do we feel um
well i'll just speak for myself here i'm
not gonna put it on you all
um how quickly do i feel entitled
how quickly do i complain how quickly do
i become
embittered how quick i am to point the
finger at others it's their fault
it's not me it can't possibly be me i'm
an angel
it's them it's them and uh i mean notice
in
in this story they were pointing the the
finger kind of at moses right because
often it's the leader or some authority
figure over us that we kind of like
so as a teen you know it's my parents
they are keeping me down you know as an
adult
it's my boss or it's pastor brett um
and then you know pastor brett i'm like
well it's the bishop right
okay we don't have a bishop but i would
do that probably
um having a bishop that would be awesome
so uh all right so this is
this is what they're doing it's the you
know it's your fault moses
you're the worst and so the lord sends a
plague upon them
snakes venomous snakes and they begin
biting the people
and as you heard well they change their
tune real quick
they're like oh i pray for us moses
we're sorry we're sorry we sinned
against you we sinned against the lord
we're foolish people pray pray moses
pray take these snakes away from us i
don't want these snakes
in my life anymore this is effectively
what they're saying like get these
things
out of here now here's my question and
this is where i'm drawing a little bit
from td jakes
um because he basically asked he said
have you ever prayed a prayer like that
and i was like okay yeah i never thought
of the snakes in this way
but basically as this problem right have
you ever prayed a prayer of
just take this away god
take this away whatever this is take
this
situation away this suffering away
remove this pain remove this problem
remove this struggle remove this
challenge remove this trial like
i am done take it away
lord you ever been there i mean i've
prayed that kind of prayer
and you know why we pray these prayers
is because
i mean basically we got a snake problem
right snakes
everywhere in our life we got uh
snakes in finances in in your marriage
uh in your social life right relational
conflict snakes in your business makes
um often with kids our children at work
at your school um snakes in a culture
that just won't accept you
snakes in a in a person you simply
cannot
bring yourself to forgive uh snakes in
your health snakes in your layoffs
snakes in the abuse you suffered as a
child
snakes in the addiction you cannot shake
snakes in the mortgage
that's coming due soon snakes in the
biological clock
that is ticking in the way that tortures
your mind snakes in the shame
that stalks you snakes in the fear that
give you no rest
snakes everywhere
and what's happening they are biting us
and they are giving us no
peace and so it's no wonder
that we and the children of israel pray
lord
take the snakes away
that's verse seven take the snakes away
we've
and we've all been there uh i mean
really on a serious note like
think back to those nights like tears
in the night as you're laying in your
bed and just those tears that just form
and run right down the corners and
you're just
begging god like i cannot handle this
take this away i am i am
done with this no more so what happens
verse 8 the lord said to moses
make a snake
make a snake and put it up on a pole
anyone who is bitten can look at it
and live verse nine so moses made a
bronze snake and put it up on
a pole uh did you catch it
like did he just say make a snake
uh god i think what you meant was
make a beautiful bronze angel with
flowing wings
uh make a a heart a beautiful
valentine's day heart and put it up on a
pole to symbolize god's love for all
people
or or just heck take the snakes away
let's see how about that that's simple
we don't even need like symbols and you
know acts of faith looking at them we
don't need to
just get rid of these snakes uh no no
that's not what he says make a snake god
has moses
make an image of the very thing
that was hurting them and and then what
happens when they
look to it then god healed them
you see that when they look at the very
thing that's hurting them
god uses it to bring their healing and
then what's so beautiful
is um that second passage that graham
read for us the the apostle john in
chapter three he picks
up this image this image
of a savior who takes on
our sin who carries our shame
john picks up this image of a suffering
savior jesus
who takes on the very shape the very
form
of the thing he sought to destroy right
jesus
jesus became sinful suffering humanity
he became as martin luther says uh
what he was not jesus became what he was
not
so that we the human family we might
become what we
are not right we would think that god
would use
right to defeat wrong good to defeat
evil
but in the same way that god told moses
to make an image
of the very thing hurting the people
so that the people could be healed so
god on the cross
uses evil to defeat evil he uses sin
to defeat sin he uses suffering to
defeat
suffering he goes down into death
to defeat it it it reminds me
so much of uh of the apostle paul
in second corinthians 12. we'll read it
in in just a minute but
um here paul has what he he describes um
if
the thorn in my flesh is the quote
and and he's using this metaphorically
it's some sort of um
suffering or trial or temptation
many theologians and christians down to
the centuries have like
very much you know imagine like what
could this be you know is it a
is it like a sin temptation he just
keeps giving in to like an addiction or
um is it a sickness and illness and
honestly we don't know
um but we do know he he connects it
directly not to god but
he connects it directly to satan all
right
the enemy and and he says some some
messenger from
satan himself uh was afflicting me
and i begged god paul says that's the
language i
begged god begged him to remove it does
that sound familiar
to defeat it to take it away
three times paul says i begged
god in prayer and then suddenly paul
had this this mystical um
encounter with christ and and where
christ like speaks
to paul and in fact um he gave him an
answer
so paul asked a question like please
take this away and christ spoke to him
and um you know what he effectively said
he didn't use this exact language
but he effectively said uh
no that's what he said
here's the exact quote but christ said
to me
my grace is sufficient for you
for my power is made perfect
in weakness my grace is sufficient for
you
for my power is made perfect in weakness
is christ's point that the more wimpy we
are
the more you know whiny and immature we
are a gay week
the better uh no that's not what he's
saying i said i think he's describing
what it means to take up our cross and
follow him
is it interesting how we're so happy to
like sing the worship songs you know
i'm letting go
it has no problem so easy easy to sing
sometimes at least when we're feeling
good uh
hard to live right but this is what he's
talking about he's describing what it
means
to shoulder our suffering to experience
that moment when we are humbled
and we come to the end of our own
strength our own power and it's then
that god does his soul building
work it's then that the virtues of
faith hope and love begin like the great
roots of a tree to burrow down
deep in our souls it's then
right when we're suffering it's then
that our ego our
our natural self-centeredness and
self-obsession
is crushed and we begin to die to
ourselves
and christ is born within us
god begins to happen in us
the great psychologist and writer and
thinker carl jung he was a
man who spent decades reflecting
on human development and he put it he
put it this way
he said no tree it is said can grow
to heaven unless its roots
reach down to hell
and this is why when you meet someone
uh who who just has a certain maturity
right they they um and they bear they
they embody the fruit of the spirit the
results of the spirit of god in our life
which
are love joy peace patience kindness
goodness gentleness faithfulness and
self-control
no matter what they're going through
it's like they continue to faithfully
not perfectly but faithfully embody that
when you when you come across someone
like that it is something
um to thank god for it is something even
to admire in them
because the only way that the leaves
of their life are brushing heaven is
because the roots
of their life have encountered hell
and this is why when paul was suffering
with we don't know with what was some
thorn some
deep emotional or physical pain he prays
to christ
take it away and this is why christ says
my grace
is sufficient for you my
grace is sufficient for you for my power
is made perfect in weakness
you see friends the healing follows
the wound the good that god wills
follows the evil that the devil wills
the beauty of your character rises from
the ashes
of your lowest moment the garment of a
life of continual praise
is woven during the season of mourning
and the rumblings of the shout of
triumph
rises from the moan of your defeat
the leaves of your character kiss the
heavens
because the roots of your testing have
gone
down to hell
you see brothers and sisters we've all
got
snakes in our life we've all got them
the question is are we running from them
or are we looking to them
do we understand that god is using them
not causing using them to
form and to shape you into the very
image of his
son jesus christ that's the question
and all um i want to close with this you
know we live in a day and age
um when when we are often trying to
shield those we love especially our
children
um from all of the suffering you know
trying to protect them from
all of the consequences and the dangers
um
and there's a level of this that that
can be good right we need to do that for
our kids but
but there's a you know a level of
helicopter parenting that can become
unhelpful
right we're trying to smooth out the the
path
right their path to the forest of life
we're trying to like smooth it out
rather than giving them a good pair of
boots
and um in his book anti-fragility
uh nassim telev is writing about this
actually linked to in my e-letter this
this past friday this this section from
tele
and um he's talking about the idea of
being
anti-fragile i think this is a really
interesting idea
um anti-fragile is not the same as
strong or
resilient right if fragile is like glass
where you drop it you know drop a glass
it breaks
uh resilient would be like plastic if
you drop plastic of course it doesn't
shatter it's very strong right
but anti-fragile is different the idea
of anti-fragile it means
the more you stress it the stronger it
grows
you see where i'm going the more you
stress it
the stronger it grows for example your
immune system is like that it actually
needs some stress
to grow your bones are like that they
need some stress to grow
and i would say your soul is like that
i mean imagine a person who's never
suffered or struggled
in any way until adulthood what kind
what kind of an adult would they be
capable
mature ready for the world no
no the metaphor that tele ultimately
uses to illustrate this this
call for us to be anti-fragile is that
of fire
he says um notice notice that fire
can be anti-fragile but it has to get
big enough
because you know you know like a candle
flame it's a very it's a fragile thing
just a little puff it's out
but think of a campfire what happens
when you blow on a campfire whoosh
and this is why nasim telev he he says
this in his book antifragile
he says be the fire
and wish for the wind be the fire
and wish for the wind don't run
from the snakes in your life my friends
don't complain
about the thorns in your flesh embrace
them
look to them god is using them
to fashion you into the very image
of his son be the fire
wish for the wind let me pray for you
lord jesus
we need um we need this reminder
not to run from our pain
not to run from our suffering
so i pray over this this community of
people who
um each person hearing my voice right
now has their own
snakes in their life
giving them no peace and god i pray
that you would use it use them to
do a deep and maturing work
god heal us give us strength
make us anti-fragile
help us to bear one another's burdens as
best we can
to be there to help as best we can
but ultimately god help us to do
business with you
and to find that deep deep peace that
passes all understanding that transcends
the day-to-day circumstances of our life
yeah be with us give us the strength we
need
in christ's name i pray amen
[Music]
is
could all that
be is could a garden come
out from this ground
[Music]
you
you make me
[Music]
hope
and is of chaos
[Music]
please
beautiful things you make
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
you
me
[Music]
hey john you're
[Laughter]
oh that's funny that would have been
good
so anyway as i was saying
[Laughter]
uh so i want to thank everyone for able
to join
us tonight and if you are in need of
prayer or
support um if you wouldn't mind you can
send us a
message um to the table in our facebook
message or
um just just send us a message so we can
uh be able to reach out
and be able to meet your needs um
and then also as we close let me just
send you out with
this benediction um it's from numbers
um so may the lord bless and keep you
may the lord make his face shine upon
you and be gracious
to you and may the lord lift his
countenance
upon you and give you peace thank you
and have a
good rest your evening bye
you